hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that came to my live Q&A on
Twitch this is gonna be a portion of
that video just cut down if you guys
want more of it all upload more of it I
think we stream for about an hour and a
half or so I name the winners of the
book three DVDs at the end of the video
and I will be posting a couple more
Legend of Korra videos in the next
couple of days and then I'll move on to
some Last Airbender videos I'm totally
loving all the suggestions you guys have
for new anime series to watch so feel
free to keep leaving suggestions in the
comments and if you guys want to do more
live twitch q and A's please let me know
too this is only for my channel in the
description if you don't know about it
just general spoiler warnings for
everything on the show so far and fair
warning that this is like the raw uncut
stream so this looks very different from
the normal Q days that I post so enjoy
hey everybody how's it going I don't
know I always fail at this this this
moment this is mostly gonna be a Q&A but
I've wanted to fire up the Corey game
I'll mostly be looking at the chats I'm
probably gonna be dying quite a bit yeah
I saw the change that or thing Bryke has
already said that this is they're
basically done with Korra story is on TV
so like I mean even if they you know
even if you got like a thousand like a
million signatures like they probably
still wouldn't do another series they
will do like they'll do more cartoons
favorite character I mean I really liked
opal but we didn't see a whole lot of
her element let's see I would probably
want to be an airbender you know because
then I could fly although technically
firebenders can fly to like the really
proficient ones
well the lava bender ii think that's
still kind of in question you could
argue that it's because one of his
parents was a firebender but our junior
and kuvira he well he still loves her he
just can't figure her out
soohyun's comment i don't you know like
yesterday you know why did she do that
in sunni and said i don't know she's
just a complicated woman that's that's
probably the best answer she could have
given some people are just really
complicated and like you'll never figure
them out hints of course ami so I mean
as the showrunners explained it at the
beginning of book 3 like when they had
that car ride together like they just
wanted Korra to have a friend
it was a girl like get just to get
things away from the like break break
said teenybopper which is like a funny
old person thing to say that's like
something that my grandpa would say but
they wanted her to have like an adult
friendship that had nothing to do with
the man although they did have that
awkward mock oh stuff between them but
they just they kind of like brushed over
it like they got past that they were
like okay let's be friends you know it's
funny that we both had this one
boyfriend that was the same yeah I mean
I did cry like a little bit mostly like
usually it's like the music in
combination with the moment like if
there if there wasn't like a really
awesome soundtrack it wouldn't connect
with me as much emotionally they just
meant the end it's the same as the
letters at the end of The Last Airbender
series they actually they just they
didn't have the English translation
underneath them just because I think
they felt that the fans were a little
bit smarter Nickelodeon probably made
them put the end under under The Last
Airbender title the closest I came to
crying was when the spirit portal opened
I didn't cry like during the wedding
scene or I'm not crying right now no I
didn't I didn't cry during like the
korrasami ending or like any of that
stuff no they were actually on air
temple Island that's where the the
wedding was the wedding was traditional
Water Tribe wedding but it was performed
on air Temple island Varrick is from the
Water Tribe that's that's why that's why
it seemed like a Water Tribe wedding no
Nik Nik doesn't care about the the homo
homosexuality it's just it's just for
broadcast purposes there are certain
rules like they have certain guidelines
yes correct Varrick is from the South
Water Tribe sir ik Nik blackstone
varrick I was I was so happy to find out
their full names and Zhu Li moon I don't
think that we had heard those before
that I don't think they had said them
out loud Mike and Brian have absolutely
nothing to do with the quantity of
episodes Nickelodeon just said we know
we want 59 are they I think it was like
they ordered the first 13 or so they
ordered booked one basically like
completely
before they ever saw any Legend of Korra
like when they brought it back they're
like hey we want a new you know sequel
to the Avatar series so Mike and Bryan
came back with Legend of Korra and then
after that Nick renewed them for an
additional like they ordered an extra of
56 episodes and then they broke those
into the separate books poll to vote on
anime well I will be doing Last
Airbender videos but yeah I mean I will
be on the lookout for new anime series
you know I'll point it this way so we
can look at the nice cars go by if there
was a spirit that knew everything and I
could ask him I would actually probably
ask him for a complete history of the
avatar line they're really only a
handful of avatars that we have
information about there's been you know
it's been ten thousand years since the
time of avatar Wan so think about how
many avatars that is like that's a lot
of avatars a legend core comic very good
question
so the next avatar comic the one the
next confirmed comic smoke and shadow
that's gonna be released like it's like
September 2015 will be the first part of
that why not Aang well it's a series
about Korra that's why I'm Malia I'm
always surprised by why people keep
asking about The Last Airbender
characters when it's not a series I can
add a series about them
speaking of which like I think it might
like my biggest complaint about the the
finale this Vic the way they broadcast
it you know who wants to watch something
at like 12 o'clock at night there were
things that I enjoyed when it was on TV
is that like just everyone knew like the
one time that it was gonna be on so it's
like you could all be on line together
and there was a bit more of a cohesive
conversation in the fandom yeah I mean
this that's the problem it's like when
it's online and people wait to watch it
it's like you completely missed like the
craziness of that midnight crowd that
was actually a lot of fun that was fun
live tweeting like it at midnight last
night but our jr. yeah yeah he'll be
forgiven he was brainwashed by kuvira
and her beautiful beautiful face not not
literally not like Dai Li brainwashed he
was brainwashed by love I I forgive him
if he had killed someone I don't think
that he actually killed anyone
then then that would have been like
crossing the line then I would have been
able to forgive him
there's another avatar series well like
you know how much time but was there
between Avatar The Last Airbender that
was like I think that ended in a 2005
legend of course started in 2011-2012 so
at about seven years - now what we did I
mean we spent a lot of time in the
spirit world in book 2 they try not to
do the exact same thing every single
season but because of the vaatu
storyline that was like you know heavy
spirit world
yeah like we'll see how Rohan turns out
he seems pretty benign I mean I think
he's maybe like Melo's age in book 1 I
want to say maybe a little bit younger
than that thank you thank you for the
nice comments I enjoy making videos I
would say like probably the most fun
thing about YouTube is like making
videos and talking to people
corn Bolin they just didn't have time
like they didn't have an extra five
minutes for core to have a scene with
everybody you probably did talk to Bolin
because I mean think about how much time
passed between the end of that wedding
and the wedding was like in the middle
of the day so that was like 12 hours so
like yeah she probably did walk around
and talk to everyone no I don't think
that break is ever gonna buy the rights
to Korra it gets easier for Mike and
Bryan to just create something original
that they can own a hundred percent of
based on the events of the finale it
seems like she is not going to reconnect
with her past avatars
thanks yeah that the headphones they're
just like razer standard headphones
they're they're really shitty for
listening to music pretty comfortable
and they block out sound so like if i
need it to be like super quiet then i'll
put the headphones on because they're
doing construction right next to my
apartment so like sometimes it's really
loud outside Sue's father I'm still want
to believe that it's Sokka
there wouldn't be like that incest thing
going on with Tenzin and you know the
son of Aang with Toph and Lin beifong
Christmas I think I mean they have
holidays but no I mean Christmas is a
Christian holiday there's a Christianity
doesn't exist in the Avatar world Last
Airbender verse Legend of Korra so it I
mean it depends on what you're looking
for in a cartoon series if you're
looking for like a very traditional hero
attains power hero defeats villain a
narrative that last airbender is better
korra is much more complex than that
like they're both very different shows
they both have like their strong points
yeah so okay the the
Saamy thing there's been a lot of posts
about it it's it's left open to
interpretation like on purpose like it's
purposefully ambiguous so that you could
you could argue one way or the other if
you take it at like the literal
interpretation they're just like really
close friends so like it's like think
about two two girlfriends not like
sexual girlfriends but like they might
loan each other like a pair of pants
they might sleep in each other's beds
like without it being sexual women are
much less likely to say like no homo or
something stupid like that like that's a
bro thing they're just like much more
open with being affectionate without
being sexual but in the subtext though
it's like maybe there is something going
on because of the way the the way they
look into each other's eyes is like a
very it's like a very intimate image
hopefully you guys enjoy that I'd love
doing live stuff but congratulations to
this week's giveaway winners or the
finale giveaway winners fantastic ideas
and Matt Brown you win copies of the
book 3 DVD please contact me on my
channel for details so we can just
arrange some communication information
while you guys are waiting for more core
bonus videos there's some Doctor Who
stuff that I'm working on this coming up
Doctor Who Christmas special happening
next week get really excited about that
it's gonna be a lot of fun it'll be
ridiculous and I'm working on a bunch of
other non core bonus videos too so lots
of fun stuff coming while you guys are
waiting for all that stuff to happen in
case you're on your mobile phone or on a
tablet there's new links up here for
extra stuff it's the same as the links
over here but click here for my finale
video and click here for all my other
legend decor videos thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you